i want to play a game with you and i
think as we play this game
we'll unpack uh kind of a lot of the
uh techniques that you use to do this
and really become the best in the world
at it
uh let's start with melinda gates so my
understanding of the situation is uh
melinda gates had done press before but
never kind of
exclusively by herself in a profile
format right no one had ever written the
melinda gates approved profile of her
right you were able to successfully do
that how do you
meet her how do you convince her to do
it and then what was the process like
actually writing that kind of first
exclusive profile of her
i gosh i spent a couple of years
talking to and writing letters
to um
the gates foundation and her people
and she had done quite a lot of press
with bill as they were building the
gates foundation
but she had never she had never agreed
to do an interview for
a profile about her
so i wanted to do the first major
profile
and i don't know finally i got in it was
the
i remember i went to seattle
the monday after or the tuesday i guess
it was after
labor day in 2007
and i remember the the new head of pr
for the gates foundation
was a woman named heidi sinclair she's
one of my closest friends today i stayed
friends with her and
um she was like her first week on the
job and melinda was so nervous and i
ended up interviewing melinda like three
times for that story once in new york
and
i interviewed bill in seattle separately
for that
and i interviewed you know a bunch of
that and i melinda was great though
like she um she let me talk to her best
friend you know i went over to her best
friend's house
on the lake and you know to her house
and like had coffee and we're sitting in
the kitchen and i'm talking about
melinda
and like melinda had never told her
story melinda had never talked about how
when she was young right out of duke and
duke university and working at microsoft
you know
kind of low level and she was walking
across the parking lot someday
and she saw the ceo the founder bill
gates and she said hello to him
and he asked her out and
and and anyway they fell in like she
she really dished and oh my god it was
fantastic they lined up bono for me
and i remember i talked to bono and
so it was great i mean they really went
all out and then
the story came out right at christmas
time
and i got the nicest email over
christmas from melinda
um telling me she was with her parents
and
her parents actually loved it loved the
story and that was a cover story
and that was you know like the ultimate
like quintessential like brand of stamp
of approval
and then my mother died three weeks
later and
my mother loved loved loved that story
that was like the
her favorite story of all that i had
done and that was
i had been at fortune for 24 years at
that point so
um wait no uh 84
two thousand had been at fortune for 24
years at that point so in a quarter of a
century that was the favorite story that
she
so it holds a lot of meaning to me for
various reasons yeah and what was like
the biggest surprise to that whole
process right when she agrees you go and
you talk to everyone you talk to bill
um you kind of hear all the stories was
there one thing that kind of stood out
to you that
was either a surprise or or you didn't
really understand until you had done all
the work
so i forgot to i actually went i already
knew warren
buffett well at that point but i had
never been out to omaha
so i went out to omaha for that story i
mean i could have interviewed warren on
the phone
but i you know i said i think i said to
him i said this would be a good chance
for me to finally come out
and you know see you in your office so i
went out
and they had announced the giving
pledge together where warren
warren who did not expect to give
any of his money away until
he died and he thought his wife susie
would die
uh he thought he would he he never
imagined that he would outlive his wife
susie so here he is he lost his wife he
has all this money
doesn't know what to do with it doesn't
have to be a philanthropist
he says it's harder than making money so
he announces
this was before this couple few years
before the story came out
he announces that he's giving all his
money to the gates's
to distribute because they're experts
so anyway that's why and obviously
as most people know bill and melinda and
warren are
really close so i went out to omaha and
here's the answer to your question
warren tells me how
ins to an extraordinary degree
melinda kind of
first of all convinced bill to give
his money away during his lifetime
and you know i can't remember the
details but convinced warren also of the
value of that because there are all
these diseases around the world and
children are dying people are dying
every day and
you know let's not save it let's put it
to good use
and warren just i mean there's that
that sort of aha moment wow that's what
we should do with our money
but warren loves
melinda because melinda has done
for bill what susie
did for warren which is basically
take a nerdy guy who is like
all business and all numbers
and
finds the kind of humanity
in him and so it's one of the reasons
that warren and bill are so close
and it's one of the reasons that warren
and melinda are so close
because he sees a lot of susie and
melinda
i love that story yeah um you
and martha stewart while she's in jail
tell us that story
absolutely epic oh geez
i had met martha in 1998 when i did a
story called it was a cover story
for fortune called women's sex and power
and it was an idea that i had to do a
story about i literally walked into the
office of the top editor of fortune at
the time
john huey and said i think we should do
a story about women who are doing better
than men
and he goes what do you mean i said well
women who are like
doing amazing things that no man has
ever done or know man
so anyway long story short
through that story i met martha
i actually had a sort of an evening with
her and
and two of her friends um
charlotte beers who was the head of
ogilvy and made her the big ad agency at
the time and a woman named darla moore
who i ended up doing a cover story about
the following year
do you know darla moore is anthony
she would be of interest to a lot of
your
a lot of your listeners because she was
the she
she was the wife of the late richard
rainwater do you know who richard
rainwater
i do yeah yeah big self-made billionaire
but anyway so i met i met
martha in 1998 one night at the
apartment of charlotte beers
with darla moore in new york
um we started two years later we
fortune started fortune most powerful
women
which was which started as a list of the
50 most powerful women in business we
put martha on the list
for several years she was building her
empire
then she lied about a stock trade
and she got convicted i went to the
trial
i was in touch with her during the trial
i knew her
i had written about her um
she got convicted she got sent
down to a prison in west virginia for
five months
and then served five months house arrest
and during the time that she was in
prison
and by the way i mean i think that
it was sort of a travesty i mean she
lied to investigators
and she paid really really big
and i'm just gonna fast forward to for a
second like the way she
handled that gives us all
provides lessons for us all in dealing
with adversity because she handled it
in the most amazing and
quite frankly classy way but anyway when
she was in prison
i uh i wanted to do the first story
about her after she got out of prison
and i i ended up sending her
magazines every week
through her assistant who sent a bag i
think every friday down to west virginia
and so i would send over to julia at
martha stewart living on the media
a packet of the magazines at time inc
we used to get them they'd all be
displayed we could all grab them
people time sports illustrated
and put together a packet every week and
send them
down and martha really appreciated it
you know this was before
i mean this was like 2004
i mean the internet people were reading
on the internet but not as much people
were really
still like reading physical magazines
so anyway she got out of prison uh they
wouldn't let me see her
uh there was a whole army of pr people
around her
no no no no no she's not doing
interviews
and she called me one day and she said
come on monday morning i think she
called me like on a saturday
and she called me she said i'll i'll
talk to you let's talk about this story
you want to do
come monday morning and i got a um
dial car one of those like 777 cars this
was long before uber
got a car went up to bedford new york
where she lived
and i remember right as we were pulling
up
i got a call from her pr person like her
head head pr
person oh my god what are you doing
martha just told me she called you and
invited you
oh my god so martha did this like
totally behind the back of her
advisors and it was great she was
wearing her
ankle ankle brain bracelet and we talked
and
she said let's go down to the stables
she said i only have like
20 minutes before i before i violate my
leaving this house or whatever and we
jumped in the car and we
went down to her stables and she showed
me around and i ended up
i ended up getting the exclusive like
you know she
we did a cover story where the cover
line was
it was a quote from her and the cover
line was
i cannot be destroyed
that was the line great picture of her
and that line and really
big print oh my gosh
she just hated the cover line she loved
the cover picture but she hated